à 72 ans le chanteur marcel amont un bon
pied bon oeil
les berrichons qui se sont rendus
dimanche au salon du livre d'argenton
sur creuse ont pu s'en rendre compte car
outre ses chansons écrire est devenu son
violon d'ingres
j'ai eu la chance que la société des
auteurs s'intéressent à cette petite
étude puisque ça s'appelle donc ça
s'écrit ça se dit ça se chante et il ya
des illustrations tous ainsi rendu un
peu attrayant j'avais peur la monotonie
parce que faire passer sur le tapis
roulant comme ça des dizaines et des
dizaines de petits phrases qui font tilt
ça pouvait être en face et du j'espère
que ça ne l'est pas outre les petites
phrases maxime 100 ans issus des
chansons françaises
marcel amont collectionne aussi celles
relevées dans la presse dont il est très
friand ce qui ne lui fait pas oublier la
composition d'une dizaine de chansons
nouvelles par an